oh i see i see that's how it works
all right so then uh welcome back
everybody uh
well thanks for thanks thanks for
listening to me and thanks to
ambush for his amazing deep dive and to
regret minimization in stationary mdps
and for describing the user analysis and
in such detail
uh so my approach is going to be like
slightly different
from from what ambush did what i'm what
i'm going to do now is going to be more
of
like a broad exploration
of everything that is related to uh
adversarial mdps which are mdps where
the reward function or the transition
function is allowed to change over
time so what i'm going to try to do here
is like try to understand first like you
know what is this notion of an
adversarial mvp
what is achievable in this problem what
is not achievable in this problem and
then try to give
some algorithmic ideas and show you some
basic
algorithm design principles that will
hopefully
be useful for all of you for designing
your own algorithms
and coming off it with better guarantees
and better and more practical algorithms
or at least that is the main idea
so i have a lot of material uh so yeah
please ask questions if you have some
serious questions uh
but i'm gonna i'm gonna rely on chava
and ambush to
to to answer all the minor questions
that come up on the fly all right
so with that uh let's get into it okay
so you've
seen this picture a million times
already these uh this is a
picture of a markov decision process
which is just an interaction between a
learner and an environment
the learner takes an action this is
passed on to the environment or the
transition dynamics
and this together with the current state
is going to influence the future states
of the environment
okay and what makes this problem
interesting and why we love this problem
is
the presence of this reward function
that allows us to specify all sorts of
like beautiful tasks and specify
reinforcement learning problem
so uh so this is the standard markup
decision process
uh where all these elements are fixed
the transition dynamics that is labeled
as the environment here
and the reward function is fixed uh and
these
steps are uh repeated in a number of
rounds
uh uh indexed by t in this stock
all right so this is a so this is this
is the classic setup
what we're going to be studying uh in
this talk is
uh an adversarial variation of this
problem
in which in each round t there is going
to be an external force an adversary
that is going to have the power to
change the reward function
this is going to be no longer a fixed
function of lowercase r
that acts on x and a but rather is going
to depend on time
can change between time steps and this
adversary is also going to have the
power
to change the reward function so in each
round
the next state is not necessarily going
to be drawn from
uh this fixed distribution p
given x and a but rather is going to
depend on the action of this external
force as well it is going to
change between rounds so this is
uh this is the idea this is uh the setup
that we're going to be studying
and what we're going to try to
understand is like what sort of
assumptions
can we make about the adversary that
will enable efficient learning
what is learnable in this set of what is
achievable what is not achievable right
so we're going to
try to cover all of these in this in
this one hour which is
which is a very short time for this all
right so uh
i'm gonna be evaluating uh we're gonna
be evaluating these algorithms in terms
of their regret
regret uh is again as has been defined a
few times
already during this workshop uh it's
just the gap
between the cumulative reward of uh the
learner
all right so this is this is here on the
right hand side this is the cumulative
reward
of the learner itself and we're going to
compare this cumulative reward
to the cumulative reward of a comparator
policy
right so here this comparator policy pi
is going to be
something that we try to compete with
right so we are trying to do
nearly as good as this comparator policy
and what's important in this regret
definition
is that uh is that these states these x
t
star x one star x two star this is the
sequence of uh
states that this comparator policy
would have encountered had it been
playing
instead of the learner from day one
right so this x1 star
x1 x2 star and so on these are the
sequence
this is the sequence of states uh that
uh the environment would have generated
in response to playing actions from the
comparator policy pi
so what you see here really on the left
uh
as the left term this is really the
cumulative reward
that this comparator policy would have
achieved have we
run it from day one okay on these
sequence of reward functions
rt uh that we have encountered during
learning
okay so this is somewhat related to this
concept of a policy regret
uh that chavo mentioned after the talk
of
ellen and walter we can we can discuss
more about the implications of this but
uh
i want you to internalize this regret
definition for now and understand that
the sequence of states is different for
both of these terms right so this is
like really
in a way the fair way to measure
difference
between cumulative rewards in this setup
right and
as uh as before as in the online
learning tutorials and also as in
as in as in amuse's tutorial our goal is
to
well come up with algorithms that have
sublinear regret which means
that these algorithms are actually
learning to perform uh
in a reasonable way or we are trying to
understand
limitations in terms of this regret
all right so this is going to be our
main performance measure
okay and with this in mind this is the
outline i'm going to first present some
hardness results
i'm going to show you uh some settings
in which
learning is known to be either
completely impossible or computationally
hard these are going to be learning
against non-oblivious adversaries
and arbitrarily changing dynamics and
then i'm going to
focus on the tractable scenario
of just adversarially changing word
functions
i'm gonna uh describe some key
algorithmic ideas in
in that part all right so let's start
with uh just harness results
all right so uh so there are different
types of adversaries that one can
consider
uh in in online learning as has been
described in yesterday's online learning
tutorial as well
uh so the most powerful of these
adversaries is the so-called
non-oblivious adversary sometimes also
called an adaptive adversary
so this adversary when selecting the
reward and transition functions in this
online mdp problem when selecting rt and
pt
it can take the entire history of
interaction into account right so
it can look at what your state right now
is what your past actions were and what
your past
states were and then based on this uh
based on this entire history based on
this uh missed knowledge
it is going to pick uh the reward and
transition functions okay so uh so this
is a very powerful adversary
and turns out that in this online mdp
problem
it is entirely impossible to get
sublinear regret against and
such a non-oblivious adversary that can
pick
reward and transition functions
according to
the past history all right so the so the
construction is very simple uh let me
just move this uh
little java out of the way
all right so uh so the construction is
very simple uh
for showing this property just consider
this mdp
right just with three states two actions
uh
uh the two actions that you can take in
the middle right
so one of the actions is going to take
you left
and one of the actions is going to take
you right with high probability right
so for example if you take the left
action you're going to move to the left
state with roll to 1 minus p
and then you're going to move back to
the middle state and then this procedure
is going to repeat on and on
all right so let's uh consider a reward
function
that is going to be chosen by an
adaptive adversary in the following way
you're going to get zero reward no
matter what you do
so there's a default reward for every
state that is zero uh
which is changed depending on on
the actions that you took in the past
right so this is this is why
you can already feel that this adversary
is going to be
very tricky to play against so in
particular
what what this adversary is going to do
is that
it is going to give a reward of one
to the left state if in the previous
round
you took the action that took you right
right
so you you would only have a chance of
getting a reward of one
if you took a different action in the
previous round
all right and similarly uh
the right state gets a reward if
in the previous round you took the
action
that takes you left so again you have no
chance
of getting this unit reward of one in
this
in this setup right so here you can see
that this reward function
takes the entire history into account in
a way that completely messes you up
so you can see that you're gonna be
getting
zero rewards in every single round for
all t
uh for eternity you're never gonna get
any reward
all right but on the other hand uh there
is a policy pie
such that this comparator uh total
reward
right that that is the other term in the
regret is gonna be
at least uh well it's gonna be positive
right
it's gonna be at least one half minus p
times t
right so this this policy is either the
one that
that always goes left or always goes
right
right and then just compare these two
things and then you're gonna see that
regret
has to grow at least linearly in this
mdp with this
sequence of reward functions so then you
can
say that hold on i mean we precisely
designed this regret definition to
to protect us against this right we
wanted to take
the effects of our actions into account
in the comparator sequence so like what
went
wrong here so turns out that the reward
function
rt in this example was chosen in
response to the real estate history ht
right this real trajectory that
that we went through and it was not
generated in response to the comparator
history so like
our comparator really took parts of this
reactivity into account in its
definition
but not the effect of hd
on our key right so i i understand that
this
is maybe a little bit tricky to
understand at first
uh so the bottom line here is that uh
well this regret definition is really
not
suitable for non-oblivious adversaries
so as long as the adversary can
uh play dirty with the past states
uh and pull off things like this
uh have some kind of reactivity that is
not captured by the state dynamics
you're essentially gonna be screwed and
you have no chance
of achieving some linear regret so there
are two ways
out one would be to consider like real
true policy regret
in a way that you'd really find the
comparator to take this effect of
history into rewards
into account but then basically you're
you should you should like package this
dependence already into the transition
dynamics
if you want to have something you regret
or if you want to have a tractable
algorithm so this
brings us to this idea that well okay
let's just i just assume that all this
reactivity is just packaged into the
transition dynamics
and then everything else about the
adversary is going to be uh
oblivious all right so so let's just
forget about this non-oblivious
adversary
this uh this adaptive adversary this is
just way too evil for us and let's
start caring about something that's a
little more benign right so this is
this is called an oblivious adversary
which is
which is an adversary that cannot take
this history into account when selecting
the reward and transition functions all
right
so you need to think of this adversary
as uh as nature
in the sense that nature does not care
about what you do it doesn't observe you
it doesn't try to
like actively mess you up but it can
still
be pretty pretty bad like i was trying
to enjoy a little sunbathing in the
afternoon but uh but then i got the
rainstorm so yeah that's why
my hair is not having a great day all
right so uh
so that's uh that's this oblivious
adversary uh
and this is the one that you're trying
to act against uh
in the rest of this uh of this tutorial
so then the question is okay can we
guarantee some linear regret against
such an adversary can we do anything
uh now in this setup and turns out
that well we need to still
rule out certain things so it turns out
that
learning with changing transition
functions if the adversary is allowed
to change the transition functions
around in each round
then we're going to end up with a
computationally hard
problem so we can achieve sublinear
regret
in this scenario there are algorithms
but
these are not necessarily always
computational retractable
so formally this means that there is an
adversary mdp
problem where the adversary can pick
where the oblivious adversary can pick
the transition function and the reward
function jointly in a way
uh that achieving sublinear regret on
this instance
is still going to be computationally
hard
all right so so let me just you know
show you this example real quick
uh okay and
uh is the counter example related to
the construction in covers impossibility
reside
yes it is it is very much related to
that i would say
i guess like covers impossibility result
refers to the fact that no deterministic
algorithm
can achieve some linear regret in in
well say prediction with expert advice
well yeah
or discrete predictions
yeah yeah well on a second thought this
is not so closely related let's let's
let's talk about this later because this
is a bit of a solid question
and uh i mean asking uh whether we can
put some additional constraints on an
adversary like computational budget
yeah i'm gonna i'm gonna mention
something i'm gonna mention something in
a second
okay regarding budget and stuff or
slowly changing dynamics or whatnot i
think that's
that's exactly what i'm going to be
mentioning oh i have a slide about that
which is uh which is coming up
all right all right but uh regarding
this computational hardness result
here the bottom line is that if you
consider
this notoriously hard problem of
learning noisy parities
it turns out that this problem can be
embedded in this adversarial mdp setup
you can construct adversarial mdp
instances that that correspond
to instances in the noisy parity
learning problem
which means that sublinear regret in
this problem would imply
uh polynomial excess risk guarantees
in a computationally efficient way for
uh for noisy parity learning
which is conjecture to be a
computationally hard problem
some schemes rely on this problem so it
is like really an
actual hard computational problem
yeah and the construction involves like
constructing a specific shortest path
problem for each parity uh example
really the bottom line is that that this
corresponds to an oblivious adversary
that picks uh the transition dynamics
and the reward function
jointly so this this kind of shows that
uh you cannot really hope to have
tractable and nice algorithms for this
for this setup
all right so so this is a so this is my
side remark
that actually under further assumptions
about the transition dynamics the way
that the transition dynamics changes and
the reward function changes
if you make assumptions uh you can
actually have sublinear regress and
reasonable performance guarantees
this is very recent work by pratik
guyana ronald ortner and peter rauer
and and i guess like a bunch of guys
from david simchi levy's lab i'm not
going to
list everybody there so uh
so these these works are uh
uh assuming that uh that the adversary
has some limited variation budget
in terms of the reward functions and uh
and the transition functions
all right so uh so the first here is the
total variation budget
on the the reward functions like how
much uh
the reward functions drift in total for
each uh
state action pair and the second one is
related to how much the
transition functions are going to drift
during this entire
uh capital t rounds
all right so turns out that if these
things can be bounded
and in particular if these things grow
at a sublinear rate
then it is possible to guarantee regret
well this form it's like
t to the two thirds times these
variation budget budgets
to to the power of one third
and the algorithms that can achieve this
are essentially variations of ucl
that forget all data at an appropriate
rate like
with a sliding window or using resets
or things like that okay so this is like
one way to get around this
computational hardness of changing area
addition functions
these are terms need to know how fast
the changes occur
uh i guess you know if you want to get
this rate if you want to get this
dependence on the variation budget i
think you actually need to know the
budgets
if you don't know the budgets then you
get some worse rate
that does not get this one third rate
and that is not necessarily sublinear
then
i think but uh but this is really just
from the top of my head right now
all right so so this is this much about
like this full-blown
problem where everything can change and
everything can be
uh adversarial so in uh in the second
half of the talk
i want to focus on algorithms uh for
mdps
with adversarial rewards right so we've
seen that well
non-oblivious adversaries are hard
learning with changing transition
functions are hard
let's just focus on adversarial rewards
now and try to
understand the main algorithmic ideas
there
so this whole line of work started with
the
with this paper or these papers by
2005 which turned into a method for our
paper in 2009 it's called online market
decision processes
it is really an amazing paper that
kick-started this entire field of
research
and what i'm going to do next is just
present
some of the key ideas from these papers
that underlie
pretty much all of the work that has
been done since in this field
and then i'm gonna zoom in and talk
about like specific algorithms
all right so formally we're gonna be
studying this problem
it's a sequential interaction problem
that uh takes place in a
a number of rounds in the trans to learn
observes the state xt
and then the learner takes an action a t
the adversary selects a reward function
that maps state action pairs to
two rewards that are bounded in zero one
and then the learner is going to earn
the rewarded correspondence it's
state and action this is going to be
denoted as capital r
and then after this the learner is going
to observe some feedback which is either
the entire reward function
uh lowercase r or in the case of
bandit feedback all that the learner
observes
is just the reward that it earned
capital rt
and then after this the environment is
going to produce a next state from the
fixed
transition dynamics because we agreed
that from this point on the transition
dynamics is going to be fixed all right
so xt plus 1 is going to be drawn
from this fixed distribution and just to
make
life a little bit easier and algorithm
design a little bit easier
i'm going to just adjust this a little
bit to say that the learner
is actually going to select a stochastic
policy pie t in each round
rather than selecting uh selecting an
action right so first the learner is
going to select pi t
and then it is going to pick an action
uh a t
from this stationary stochastic policy
with uh so this is going to be the
distribution pi t
of the next action given the current
state xt
all right so stochastic policies uh just
a recap it's a distribution of
over actions given the current state all
right so this is the protocol
uh and let's see what is the biggest
problem
in this uh in this learning problem well
the biggest problem here
is or the biggest challenge here is all
the crazy temporal dependencies that
these key objects have and
all the complicated ways in which things
depend on each other right
so uh uh so basically what happens here
is that the adversary
selects a reward function in the
previous round this is going to
influence the policy in round t
and the policy and the current state
together are going to influence
the action that the learner picks and
then this state and action are going to
influence the next state
and then this goes on and on and on and
the policy
is going to influence the policy in the
future
right so this is uh this is a possible
schematic
for an algorithm that uh takes the
reward function into account
when picking the policies right so uh so
this is a reasonable algorithm template
for full information learning because
they're
the reward functions or well the actions
of the learner
do not have direct influence on the
policies i can talk about this more
later
so nevertheless what i'm trying to
convey here is that
well this is a very complicated picture
uh in order to
sort of simplify analysis what we can do
is uh
sort of try to decompose this problem
into smaller problems
so let's say that we just start with
studying this top part first
the influence on the reward functions
and the policies and try to understand
the dynamics
in this space and then worry about the
rest a little bit later about how all
this interacts with the actual evolution
of the states and the actions
so in particular what you're gonna the
trick that you're gonna pull off
is that we're gonna pretend that every
policy or at least in the analysis at
first we're going to pretend that every
policy is going to reach
its stationary distribution immediately
right
so in each round t i can pick a policy
pi t and i can immediately go to its
stationary distribution
get the corresponding reward and then
do this in every single round so just
abstract away
everything that is related to the exact
dynamics
i know that this sounds abstract right
now uh this is gonna
uh this is gonna be exactly defined on
the next slide
okay so two two questions appeared in
the meanwhile
uh ononimus attendee asks uh does this
adversary
it only observes all the past actions
and state pairs that already happened
uh well so so our adversary right now is
not allowed to observe
the states and the actions at all so the
encounter example that i showed it works
for whatever
if it's some set of actions or subset of
states
no it's it's hard okay the other
question
uh youtube zhang uh if you consider the
episodic mdp setting and adversary word
and transition
one thing that the agent can do is to
reduce the problem into a bandit problem
but each arm corresponds to a
deterministic policy
so you have a to the power of s arms
and the problem becomes an adversarial
bandit problem
where each episode becomes his time step
then the agent should be able to get
an o e to the
s square t regret how does this relate
to the computational hardness result
uh gerges yeah so
so this algorithm would need to maintain
a set of weights
for all the policies right and and this
is going to be exponentially large
in the state space so this is not going
to be a polynomial time
algorithm that is polynomial time in the
input size right
so this is what i mean by
computationally hard uh that
there is no known polynomial time
algorithm that uh that works for it
right yeah but yeah it's a very good
clarifying question
i hope that my answer makes sense yeah
so in a way this whole thing is about
removing uh the memory barrier or
computational barrier
yeah rather computational yeah and both
the memories
the regret uh yeah it depends on so
so uh should you say that the regret is
going to be exponential but
it is actually uh if it was the full
information
setting right then the number of actions
is going to be in a log
so then your s you have square root t
guarantees are going to be reasonable
but uh but the computational time is
going to be awful so it's going to be
exponential in the number of states
and the bandit feedback would make it
very strong
yeah this is probably ways of exploiting
the structure and getting something that
is spotted on the number of states
still computational will be a mess
right okay great questions uh
yeah but uh it's like back to where i
was so what we're going to be doing
is that we're going to be pretending
that every policy is going to
immediately reach its stationary
distribution
just to sort of simplify the problem uh
and here you can see the definition of
the station or distribution of
policy pi like uh i guess ambush already
showed this
so this is really just that you look at
the distribution of states over a very
long time window
and then you let the time window the
length of this time without going to
infinity this
is the stationary distribution so all of
these results that i'm going to be
showing are going to be using this
assumption
about one step mixing in the mdp that
implies that that every policy has a
unique stationary distribution and
every policy mix is fast towards the
stationary distribution so here this
number this tau
thing that you see over here this is
what i'm going to be calling the mixing
time and
well we can we can discuss more and the
importance of this particular
assumption let's just accept that this
implies unique station distributions and
fast mixing
all right so let's do this so let's
just start working in the space of
stationary distributions
and see if you can get some ideas for
deriving algorithms okay
so here are a couple of definitions
that are going to be necessary i'm going
to define nu of t
of x and a so this is really just the
marginal distribution of states and
actions
uh of our policy of our algorithm
right so this xt is the real state that
you see and 80 is the real
action that we take this is the
probability that we take
uh state action pair xa in round t
nutty star is going to be the same thing
for the comparator policy for the
optimal policy that you're trying to
compete with right so nu t star
is the probability that in round t
uh this comparator policy is going to
see
state action pair x and a right then i'm
going to define
the corresponding stationary
distributions as well so like mu t
is going to be the stationary
distribution corresponding to policy pi
t
that i'm playing in round t and mu star
is going to be the station distribution
that is induced by the comparator policy
pi
star right so now that i have uh
defined all of these uh i i'm gonna
rewrite my regret
as follows so my regret is well it was
defined as this
which i can simply redefine in
in the form of this inner product or
expectation so what this means is that
the regret is really just the difference
between two expectations
two expected rewards one is the expected
reward under nutty star
and the other is the expected reward
under duty right the actual distribution
of state
action pairs right so this is i i didn't
do anything tricky here but then what i
do is that i just add and subtract a
bunch of terms
to make something more tractable uh
emerge from this expression all right so
in particular what i
what i wanted to have is this term in
the middle
that i'm going to be called calling the
stationerized regret
so this is really just the cumulative
regret
in this model where i assume that i can
mix
immediately i can go to the stationary
distribution of policy by t
immediately in each round right so this
is really just the total gap
between the stationary ward of the
comparator policy the total
stationary board of the comparator
policy and
compared in each round with the
stationary reward
of policy pi t and the other two terms
i'm gonna
i'm gonna be calling these the drift
terms which
somehow measure how different these
distributions this annuity star and nu t
are from their uh stationary
counterparts
uh so basically
the algorithm design is going to be
concerned with minimizing the
stationarized regret
and controlling the rest uh well is
going to be some
uh complicated technical exercise that
i'm not going to discuss today
uh i'm just going to quickly say that
for the comparator drift
we can bound it very very easily very
very simply by a constant
using standard mixing time argument so
this entire thing is just going to be
bounded in terms of the mixing time
again you can verify these calculations
if you
if you feel like it and the other term
which is which is this uh drift for the
learner's distribution
so there the bottom line is that if your
policies are changing slowly enough
right so what this
shows is that if the difference between
consecutive policies
is not too large then uh this total
drift
that uh that you see here on the uh on
on the rightmost term
this is going to be bounded in terms of
this change rate epsilon
uh yeah i suppose that there should be
like a capital t
multiplying this term as well
yes so in any case what this what this
really means that if the policies change
slowly then this distribution nu t
this actual distribution of the state is
going to track
the stationary distribution of the last
policy so intuitively
this makes sense because you're changing
your policies very very slowly so you're
always
sort of close to being to being
stationary
and in particular you're close to the
stationary distribution of the last
policy that you've played
again this is this is not really part of
the central story that i'm trying to
tell
so so here what i'm trying to focus on
is that well
just look at this regret decomposition
there are
some terms that can be controlled in
some really painful
technical way but the real key
algorithmic insights come from
controlling the station rise regret
which is really what i'm going to uh
discuss now like how to
actually obtain algorithms uh from this
uh from this decomposition because this
decomposition plays a key role in the
algorithm design itself
so the two families of algorithms that
i'm going to be discussing uh
are what i call algorithms that are
based on a local to global or regret
that composition
like decompose this whole global regret
into local regret minimization games or
well
decompose the regret into local regrets
and i'm going to show you another
approach that is based on a reduction to
online linear optimization
uh which is going to use some of the
knowledge that uh that water hasn't
introduced yesterday all right so first
tips
okay so this uh local to global regret
decomposition as i call it
uh uh it is based on this a very very
useful technical result it's called the
performance difference lemma
uh so this idea is due to evander kagade
and mansoor
but the performance difference lemma has
a very very long history and
in control and reinforcement learning
and in or
basically what it says okay so if you
just look at it right now it's just
gonna look like a bunch of symbols
and a bunch of letters it is going to
make sense on the next slide okay
but let me just go through this it
essentially says that uh
well let's take two policies pi and pi
prime
let r be a reward function and let q pi
and v pi be the value functions that
correspond to this r
and pi then what i have is that
the expected stationary words uh the
difference between the expected session
words of pi prime and pi right so mu pi
prime minus mu pi times r is going to be
equal
to an expectation of a difference right
so it's going to be the
equal to the expectation of q pi minus v
pi which is some of you may know as the
advantage function of the policy pi
and then the expectation of all of this
taken with respect
to the state distribution the stationary
distribution induced by pi
prime okay so like i said this just
looks like a bunch of random letters but
let's apply it
to uh to this particular setup
i just apply this lemma with the reward
function being rt
policy pi being pi t and policy pi prime
being pi star
the comparator policy all right so then
uh what uh what the performance
difference lambda gives us
is that the difference between the
stationary wars of these things i guess
this should be rt
here so this uh so this is the
instantaneous regret
the instantaneous regret is going to be
equal
to uh the following thing it is going to
be an expectation over
over states x of these differences
uh the difference between pi star
and pi t evaluated at q t
right so this is really like okay pi t
times q t uh is the value function this
is v
of pi and this q t yeah sorry i forgot
to give the definition this
is uh the q function of pi t with reward
function r of t so this is what i
didn't know this q t
all right so this is like already
looking somewhat more relevant to what
we want
but then we just go from this
instantaneous regret expression
to the entire regret right the
cumulative regret
then we're gonna see that it takes this
form right
we just summed up for all t but then
what we can observe
is that well since this mu star thingy
is independent of t i can
swap around these two sums and then i
can just
look at this object right so this is the
sum over t
of the expectation of q t
under my policy and the expectation of
qt
under a comparator poles for every state
x
so then the observation in this uh in
this paper by evander kakada and masseur
was that well this exactly looks like
a regret in a local game in a state x
with a reward function qt of x
right so you can see that if i fix my x
here
this is really the exact same form
as the expression of a regret
in an online learning game where the
reward function is qtx
block right for uh for every single
action
all right so so this is this is really
the best job that i can do at explaining
this
what we just did is
equate this stationarized regret with a
bunch of
localized regrets for every state x
so this suggests a very natural
algorithm idea
let's just take a regret minimization
algorithm
just take any of the algorithms that
walter and alan have been discussing
yesterday
and let's just put these algorithms
into every single state x and feed it
feed these algorithms with qt of x
as the reward function all right so this
suggests this algorithm this is called
the mdp
expert algorithm of avendarcocca and
monsoor
uh which essentially
what it does is that after observing the
reward function it just uh
solves the average award-winning
equations
uh or the poisson equations if you like
it just calculates the q
function to put simply just calculate
the q function
and then it just feeds this q function
into an expert algorithm to be concrete
uh i just say that this alg algorithm
is gonna be the exponential weights
algorithm that we all know and love by
now
uh which really just takes our policy
uh and applies multiplicative updates to
this policy right so
my p my pi t plus 1 is going to be
proportional to pi t times
e to the eta times the reward function
that i just constructed the q
function that i just constructed all
right
okay so this so this is the algorithm
that is suggested by the regret that
composition that i've shown
and then the proof of this theorem uh
is is just absolutely trivial right so
this is
the performance guarantee of this mdp
expert algorithm
it says that if my algorithms that i'm
using in this construction
have a regret bound of b of t
then the overall regret are written the
regret
the stationaries regret of this
algorithm is going to be bounded by tau
times b of t right so sorry so this
b of t is a valid regret bound for this
algorithm if
the rewards if the inputs of this
algorithm are bounded in zero and one
but since we are using it with value
functions that are bounded in terms
of the of the mixing time we have this
extra factor of tau
in this guarantee and then if you just
go through
uh the rest of the analysis yeah if you
use exponential weights
and if you bound all the other drift
terms uh
and all that then you can arrive to this
final regret bound of this algorithm
uh that is square root of t times square
root of log
number of actions times some polynomial
of the mixing time so interestingly this
band does not depend
at all on the number of states i'm going
to get back to this a little bit later
all right but again i i don't need to
say anything more about the proof
because
like the construction that i gave was uh
was immediately implying the proof here
so there are a bunch of uh adjustments
that you can make to this algorithm
uh like you can you can adapt it to
uh to to take care of bandit feedback as
well in bandit feedback you only observe
this
the reward that you uh that you actually
get
here again you can just define define
an unbiased estimator of the reward as
in the exp3 algorithm that
that alan has so kindly explained uh
yesterday
so here this is really just using an
importance waiting trick
but here you have to be careful as to
how to define your importance ways you
need to use some special conditions in
there
you need to make some other hacks to the
algorithm this is something that
that we have done with uh with android
and java and andras
back 10 years ago in europe's
somehow somehow adjust this algorithm to
this setup
all right and then turns out that that
you can come up with great guarantees
for this
variation of this mvp expert algorithm
if you use this
importance weighted uh trick for
uh for the reward functions
right so in this bound this beta is a
uniform lower bound
on the stationary distribution of uh of
the stationary visitation probability of
every state
in that way we couldn't really get rid
of this factor it's not
really nice i'm going to talk a little
bit more about this
near the end all right
so then let me talk about this other
family of algorithms
besides that is not based on this regret
decomposition that is not
based on the performance difference
level but rather to
on the reduction to online linear
optimization
all right so uh getting back to this
definition on this stationarized regret
you can actually notice that this is uh
regret in a certain online linear
optimization problem right you can see
that
this is like a linear reward that you're
trying to maximize
with a linear comparator so this is
really just a
linear optimization problem why don't we
just
go back to our background in online
linear optimization and use an algorithm
for this
so this is something that walter has
been describing yesterday in the online
learning tutorial
uh algorithms that uh
aim to minimize regrets of this form
uh so in particular what we want to
reduce this to
is an online linear optimization
problem where the decision set
is the set of all stationary
distributions
right so here we need to regard our
decision variables
as stationary distributions because our
objective is linear in this
and then hope that we can apply this uh
this methodology all right so here our
decision set is going to be the set of
all stationary distributions which is
the set of all distributions that also
satisfy
this uh stationarity constraint which
turns out to be a linear constraint so
this is
uh so this is a convex set that is
specified by a number of linear
constraints
so in principle we can just apply all
the standard
methodology for it yeah so
this this stationary constraint
essentially says that if i start from my
stationary distribution
i take a step forward in uh in the
transition kernel
i'm going to land back at the very same
distribution this is what it expresses
all right so this is the idea let's run
online linear optimization
on this decision set and with the reward
functions that's my rewards
so in particular uh let's uh let's use
this
online mirror descent algorithm that
water also described yesterday
we could use other algorithms but i'm
just going to focus on this
so this algorithm is going to uh
perform this maximization step in each
round it is going to try to maximize the
instantaneous reward
and it also tries to stay close to the
previous
stationary distributions right so it's
going to maximize in the space of
stationary distributions
try to maximize rewards while staying
close to the previous uh
to the previous uh station distribution
all right and after we have
after we have calculated our station
distribution we can extract the policy
just by marginalizing out
the states right so our policy is going
to be proportional in each state
to the station distribution that we
calculated
so there are a bunch of different ways
in which you can choose the
regularization function
or the or the bregman divergence that
measures the distances between the
between the station distributions you
could use the relative entropy between
distributions
or the kl divergence if you like which
leads to a family of algorithms that
is now apparently known as online
relative entropy policy search
which is first well simultaneously done
by
me and my master student alex zimmerman
and by chava and andres and travis uh
back in 2014 right so that is that is
one
possible choice which i'm going to
discuss more and
but there are other legitimate choices
that lead to very interesting algorithms
for example using the conditional
relative entropy or sorry the
conditional relative entropy
uh where this logarithm
is well it really involves the policies
that uh that are on the live you and you
well anyway i'm going to be focusing on
this on this choice of relative entropy
and
online reps uh i'm going to describe
this algorithm very briefly
what this algorithm does is again based
on calculating
some value functions but these value
functions are somewhat tricky and not
very conventional and then doing an
exponential weights updates
update to the stationary distributions
so let me just start with the stationary
distribution update it's going to be a
multiplicative update
to the previous distribution uh where
the exponent
is the immediate reward plus the
expected future value minus
the current value so this is again like
an advantage function
or like uh like a bellman error if you
like
so this is what uh what the
what the update looks like but the value
function that we use for this update is
the one that minimizes
this cost function or this uh
or this loss function which is
essentially like a log
sum x of the same thing uh of the same
advantage function so to say
so here what i want to emphasize is that
this is an unconstrained convex
minimization problem that you have to
solve
for obtaining your value functions again
these are not value functions in the
sense
of solving the baman equations but
rather in the sense of
optimizing a certain cost function and
then after you have calculated this
you can calculate your policy update as
well
and i have to say that this algorithm is
called the reps or relative entropy
policy search
uh because it's inspired by this
algorithm that's called
reps simply by jan peter scattering the
mulling and
jasmine altoon from aaai 2010.
so this is this is a very popular
algorithm still in
in in robotics and reinforcement
learning i would say
all right so again uh this is this is a
nice algorithm
uh and you can prove similar guarantees
uh about it and then for the mdp expert
algorithm
uh so the stationerize regret which is
very straightforward to control because
you just
need to use the straightforward
methodology of online linear
optimization you just use the
the same analysis that walter was
showing yesterday
to this instance turns out that there's
nothing really special about this
decision set so everything
works out straightforwardly and again
get this
regret guarantee that looks like this
square root of t times log number of
states and number of actions
and if you put everything together take
into account the drifts and whatnot
then the regret of this algorithm is
going to look like this
square root of t log x a and that's
going to be a factor of square root of
tau
in this case so again
the proof is very simple given what
you've already seen yesterday
and again this can be adjusted to work
with bandit feedback uh oh
well at least sort of uh so
i don't know if anybody managed to adapt
this algorithm to work
in this uh ergodic mdp case with bandit
feedback
for uh for episodic mdps or for finite
horizon mdps
uh we have managed to do this with uh
with alex back in
2013 and in this case we get a band
that looks like this the way that it
improves over
previous guarantees that it eliminates
this assumption
of having a lower bound on every
visitation probability i'm going to have
a little table that
compares all of these
all right so so these these are really
the two families of algorithms
that that i think are
the most important for this uh
adversarial mdp
problem uh well the question is
that okay so which one should i use
really so like what
what uh what are the advantages and
disadvantages of these algorithms
so you can of course you know take this
uh
very like scholarly approach and just
you know go to your
ivory tower and just compare the bounce
and just say that okay this
algorithm has better bounce it has to be
better
so if you look at the right column here
with this reps algorithm you're going to
see that
these bonds are like well sort of better
well they have some logarithmic
dependence on a number of states but
they're
scaling with the mixing time and the
horizon in the case of finite horizon
problems
is better and and another improvement is
that
for banded feedback you actually have no
dependence on this uh
smallest visitation probability that uh
that
that you have for all analysis of the
mdp expert algorithm that i know of
so the guarantees of this online reps
algorithm are better
but there are some things uh that that
this mdv expert algorithm have
has going for it so
in my uh in my mind the very important
good property of this mdp expert
algorithm is that it works very very
well with function approximation
techniques
if you have ways of approximating the q
function
then it's very natural to uh to to plug
those into
mdp expert and well so like this
reps approach uh i think its advantage
is that
it's easier to think of if you have like
a an optimization background
and somehow its formulation allows uh
like plugging in extra constraints or
other kind of extensions into its models
so let me just start with this mdp
expert algorithm here if you remember
the form of the policies that are output
by this algorithm
uh you can see that okay i can just try
to
like estimate or like approximate the
q functions that this algorithm is using
right i just plug in a q
hat of t which is an approximation of
the q t or the q pi
of t that this algorithm was using let
me just try to
calculate an estimate for this and i can
follow this policy right which is like
an exponential weights policy
that takes all the past q estimates into
so account turns out that you can derive
algorithms with strong performance
guarantees
for uh for settings that function
approximation
with this approach for example there is
this polytex
algorithm by uh by yasin abbasi at kori
and and others that involve chava and
peter and evanna
and i guess maybe somebody else maybe
gallart and
kush okay so i think i got everybody
so here the idea is that uh is that you
just use a least squares policy
estimation
uh policy evaluation lspe to estimate
the q
function with linear function
approximation and then you can get
sublinear regret well
optical in your term that that
essentially measures how good
your your function approximation scheme
is right so
so this algorithm is and its analysis is
really just a straightforward
application of this mdp expert analysis
you just look at your approximation
errors in terms of the q functions and
see how they propagate through the
analysis it's it's fairly simple
and this is really enabled by this
algorithm structure
and there's another algorithm that
essentially does the same it's called
oppo
by kayata uh so this is again just using
least course policy evaluation to
estimate the q function
and with realizable function
approximation uh
they can show square root of t regret
which is like
the optimal scaling and they have like
reasonable scaling with the
dimensionality of the function
approximation as well so this
is well i guess this really shows that
uh that this is a very powerful approach
you can just plug in your favorite
function approximator and still get away
with it
and another very strong uh
point for mdp e is that this algorithm
is essentially
identical to uh to this very famous
reinforcement learning and deep
reinforcement learning algorithm that's
called cross-region policy optimization
or prpo
so we have uh we have a paper with under
seance and business commerce that
explains this equivalence between
between these are atoms so
so i guess this really shows that you
know these ideas are
actually very very relevant to
to practical algorithm design as well
yeah so i was going to say that that
that this o reps algorithm can
include like other constraints and
also like involve like other kind of
uncertainty modeling
in their description for example you can
just go back to your decision set
of station distributions and also
put also extend it a little bit
so that p also becomes an optimization
variable the condition model
can become an optimization variable that
comes from
a confidence set of transition models
for example you can take
the transition the confidence set that
was defined by
ambush for for our ucrl you can plug
this into this decision set and still
get a reasonable algorithm this was
first done
uh last year by rosenberg monsoor and it
has been extended to bandit feedback
by by gene and co-authors this year at
icml
where they pretty much managed to get
the first algorithm for online mvps
uh that worked with bandit information
and
no prior knowledge of the transition
function
um but i suppose i don't really have too
much time so let me just uh let me just
uh
conclude here uh so well there are a
bunch of open problems
out there mostly on the front of lower
bounds
so i think that still nobody has any
idea about
what should be the right scaling in
terms of the mixing time
tau like as you saw the upper bounds
that i was showing
they were all over the map so it's not
really clear like what is the optimal
dependence and where should we say that
okay
we know that we can stop now we don't
even know if uniform mixing is necessary
for achieving these bonds
maybe we can guarantee some bonds for uh
for communicating mdps and only assuming
bonded diameter
this i would say is completely unclear
at this stage uh
there has been some recent progress on
addressing large state spaces and
function approximation
as i said but these results are not
fully satisfactory yet so there's still
quite a bit of work to be done on that
front but i guess the biggest question
is
well so like what is really the
relevance to practice
of all of these algorithms that i've
been describing so i guess
the bottom line is that uh well the
first set of results regarding negative
results
i guess that's just useful for you know
figuring out like what are the
boundaries how far should we trying to
push
where should we stop and where should we
focus our attention a little bit more
and on the on the front of algorithms uh
well you can say that well
like trying to like figure out these
right constants and improving on each
other's balance is like not
really what people in practice care
about but i would say that uh
this whole online learning setup is
is is a very very interesting setup
because it really
uh provides us algorithmic tools
that are useful for practical
algorithms as well so in particular one
key tool in all of these online learning
analysis is that of robustness
how much does my algorithm change its
predictions
as my reward function changes
so this kind of robustness is
particularly interesting in
reinforcement learning so
algorithmic algorithmic ideas that
improve robustness
are definitely useful for more practical
rl results
and in particular the tools of
regularization that are being developed
in this field of online reinforcement
learning theory
are definitely going to be useful for
developing better algorithms
and this is this is where i always
recall that while this trp algorithm you
know this is equivalent to mdpe
so every algorithm that uh that that we
developed
can have similar impact in practical
dprl as well if you push these ideas and
implement these correctly so
i definitely think that this other
family of algorithms that i was
describing
could be one day uh beating some other
algorithms including trpo on
on interesting problems that you know
some other people care about
so with that let me just uh thank all of
you and show you this picture from 2010
uh where a lot of these results that i
was mentioning uh
well i learned a lot of these results
and i and we proved it with these uh
two excellent guys that uh i suppose you
can still
recognize so that's andre i don't know
if he's here but uh
machava and myself are both here all
right so
thank you and well if you have questions
i'm happy to answer
thank you gerge um sharon's asking a
question
uh energies for politics mvp experts was
done for adversity mvps with fast mixing
isn't there a gap versus what is being
done in practice because of stochastic
versus
adversarial and mixing if you use an
online
learning argument that achieves good
stochastic adverse settings does it
translate to a better rl algorithm as
well
well so i suppose if you have guarantees
for the adversarial case then you also
have guarantees for that for the
stochastic case
right so that's that's true but of
course here you're trying to solve a
harder problem
uh yeah and i i really
don't know okay so i guess i'm just
twisting the question right now but i
guess uh
these tools uh of like robustness and
these
soft updates and smooth updates uh
we know that they are helpful in online
learning right we know that they lead to
some linear regret
but they may be useful in
in like dealing with other kind of
approximation errors and other kind of
errors that
arise in large-scale reinforcement
learning as well
but like regarding the
regarding the gaps like what was the
question about the gap
so uh so as far as i can tell this
politics algorithm here
you have changing reward functions as
well right
i'm trying to read that facial
expression so like in
in politics you have editorial rewards
right oh are you talking to me
yeah i suppose okay
so you're the only one i can see so uh
so in politics you have adversarial
rewards
right politec uh
well we know we didn't bother oh i said
i see it right right we just focused on
the functional approximation case and
just pointing out that
uh it like this exponential
reading uh applied in a state-wise
fashion
is particularly requested to function
approximation errors
uh which is a nice thing to have so my
my answer would be that
uh function approximation is a crazy
business
it introduces all types of errors and
you need to deal with that
that's almost like an adversary acting
on you especially if you're using neural
networks
have you ever tried that uh so maybe
uh it is not too far-fetched to think
that these tools are useful
uh nevertheless you know like turning
this into
a practical argument time uh the english
uh i don't know all the practical issues
uh
it takes quite a bit of effort uh in the
meanwhile amir masood
also asked the question
uh starts with uh
saying that the composition of regret
three parts is nice and elegant but i'm
wondering whether we would lose anything
in this process
uh the the reason i think this is the
case
because the drift terms are valid uh
using only how fast the mdp mixes and
doing so we
disregard the reward generated in the
process does it matter
does this matter yeah yeah that's
that's a great question well i mean i
guess this is like
a typical uh
artifact and all these regret analysis
that you really only care about like
what happens
if t grows large and there's all these
big o's and everything so you just
people tend to disregard everything that
does not depend on t but
you're right that this may not really be
the right approach if you have
sort of a short horizon right so if your
mixing time
is is very very large it's comparable to
your
total horizon in which you're trying to
optimize your rewards
then of course you should never do this
you should do
you should follow some different
approach definitely
but i guess in that case it's sort of
dubious if you can like
learn like anything at all
efficiently in a way that that nicely
exploits the markovian structure
i think that uses a different
composition
uh which analysis the oppo
and then they do episodic so
they don't exist that's helpful uh today
they overcome the
issue that in polytech we were just
sweeping under the track which is
exploration right
no no no i mean they have they have an
episodic setting so they don't have to
worry no but even in episodic setting
you have to explore in a certain way
to cover things oh yeah right so so they
have exploration bonuses there so yeah
sorry i forgot to say that's a big
difference but for amir muscle just just
to say that
yes you can do the analysis in slightly
different ways uh
but of course in the episode extending
this uh all business stuff
drifting and mixing it's a ghost away it
mixes
yeah yeah right so so so there's many
many papers
but finite horizon episodic case
and in that setting you don't have to
decompose the regret at all i mean
they're
all that you have is just this nice part
of the regret these drifts they just go
away
all right um i need to run in here
but there's a question on discord yeah
that
um can can
uh the absence of a direct state space
dependence in the
mdp expert algorithm can more be said
about that absence
oh yeah okay so i guess that's that's
another mystery there
so if you just look at these uh look at
these results right
uh there you see that well this reps
algorithm has this dependence on the on
the size of the sa space
but its dependence on the time horizon
or the or the mixing time
is better uh whereas the mdp expert
algorithm
well it has worse dependence on the time
horizon
and the mixing time but no dependence on
the size of the state space so
this suggests that in some cases one may
be better than the other
which which is completely mystifying to
me and
and i don't know where this comes from
or whether this is
fundamental or not uh the only the only
thing that i can like
very quickly explain in uh
and very briefly is like why these bands
are different right
why why the station rights regrets are
different for for reps and mdpe
so for so for reps basically you get a
better bound
that does not scale with the mixing time
because you're directly controlling
uh the distance between uh between the
consecutive stationary distributions
and this also improves the the the drift
terms
so that's why you can shave off like
this
extra tau factors because you're
directly controlling the distance
between the consecutive
[Applause]
station distributions whereas if you do
whereas if you do uh this right if you
just run the mdp expert algorithm then
you're gonna pick up this extra factor
of tau here in the regret bond
and you're gonna pick up these extra
factors of towels and the drift terms as
well
so i can i can explain like this
difference but
uh but unfortunately not the the
difference in terms of the
the dependence on the state space
another mystery thank you that was that
was uh
very intriguing thank you thank you
ambush for forwarding the question
all right so uh so i'm reading a
question from the q a since uh
java seems to have disappeared uh
so is it possible to supplement mdpe or
all reps with an approximate model of
the environment dynamics
which one is more suitable for this goal
for example if the form of the
dynamical equations of the environment
is known but the dynamical map still has
non-stationary spectral decomposition
okay so
so regarding the first part of this
question
if it's possible to supplement or reps
or mdp with an approximate model of the
environment dynamics
i would say that this is easier to do in
in reps
along the lines of this thing the time
that i sort of rushed over
where where basically what happens is
that uh
if you just take all reps the origin the
original version that considers this
decision set
right here you know everything you know
what the transition function is
blah blah blah but in a real
reinforcement learning problem you don't
necessarily
know what p is and
so you can have some sort of uncertainty
set
of uh of of transition functions that
you can uh
that that you can augment this decision
set with
uh but and like what i was describing
here is when this uh when this
confidence set is uh well is of the form
of the ucrl confidence set
but of course you can put like other
kinds of prior knowledge
about the transition function here as
well so it doesn't
necessarily need to be uh the the ucrl
confidence sets
that kind of you know l1 thing is but
you can like
uh input some other other
prior knowledge of of destination
functioning there may be
also in the sense that uh the term that
you were asking for
is uh
i don't know it's a that's a that's a
good enough question or no
but like uh whether or not this uh this
and this can be done
in mdpe uh okay i'm i'm not really sure
yeah yeah
because mdpe is really apparently better
at handling
well like value functions and value
function estimates
uh so it is more well more of like a
value-based algorithm if you want to use
those terms
whereas this reps is more like you know
working in this kind of model space and
transition
dynamic space and it's like more
convenient
to to encode prior knowledge
into into this formulation
if that makes any sense
awesome all right
so i suppose it's uh it's lunch time
then
or whatever you call it yeah lunch time
in a certain time zone
the pacific time zone yeah yeah well
here it's almost 9 pm
oh my god my break can only take so much
science at this time
yeah i think uh we start in about
i don't know like 20 no wait a minute 30
for 40 something minutes
emma will do a tutorial on the batch
side of things
by charles oh yeah yeah
awesome i should catch my breath before
that
yeah right so i forgot to say that
there's like a bunch of references in
there so i actually
took the time to copy them in there
yeah so i think the zoom just stays on
that's the way it has been and we just
reconvene um at uh
12 30 pacific 3 30 eastern yes very good